[Music]
recaptcha enterprise helps protect your
website from fraudulent activity
spam and abuse recaptcha enterprise
helps protect your website by stopping
malicious actions
such as fraudulent transactions and
false posts while allowing legitimate
users to interact with your website and
without interruption
recaptcha has been defending millions of
sites for almost a decade
and the recaptcha enterprise service
builds on this technology with
capabilities
such as two-factor authentication and
mobile support designed specifically for
enterprise security concerns
there are several threats that can
target your web applications as a result
of malicious web automation
credential stuffing is one of them and
we'll take a look at how recaptcha
enterprise can stop credential stuffing
credential stuffing is when there are
mass login attempts used to verify the
validity of stolen username and password
pairs
if we go to the recaptcha enterprise
admin portal in google cloud platform
we are able to see the response of a
legitimate action from a real user
due to a couple of key metrics number of
requests is a simple count of how many
assessments have been made with a
particular recaptcha key every time the
user hits a page that the customer has
instrumented
the count should go up by one these
assessments are scored
and we give three color-coded buckets to
help visualize this
low risk medium risk high risk
score distribution returns a score based
on interactions with your websites
with 1.0 being a likely good interaction
and 0.0 being a likely abusive action
enterprise calculates this risk score by
using machine learning models based on
user behavior patterns
top 10 actions is a view of the number
of requests but instead of separated by
date
they're separated by action actions are
defined by the user when they instrument
their site
particularly to be able to analyze this
data separately from other actions
for example you might want to tell apart
the traffic from the home page
rather than the payment page top 10
risky actions
is when actions are being sorted by
percentage of risky traffic
congratulations you've successfully used
recaptcha enterprise to help protect
your business from credential stuffing
and other web-based attacks visit
recapture enterprise google cloud to get
started with recaptcha enterprise
[Music]
you